Jay Bilas joining us on the program Jay
what's on your mind today
not much Dan I just well first I am
really glad you are hosting undeniable
that's one of one of my favorite shows
and you are a fabulous interviewer in
fact I think I think you are still the
only the only broadcast journalist to
ever be shouted at by a commissioner
from the podium during the draft when
David Stern jumped down your throat I
don't know how many years ago or so we
were working to go yeah yeah that was
that was a rough rough draft night there
for me when the commissioner shouted out
because I was told
we're told the commissioners coming out
with the card so I said and let's go to
the commissioner and he didn't come out
so I said Commissioner like I was like
come here come on out wherever you are
and then he came out and they verbally
spanked me but you know he's verbally
spanked me a few times there I think it
was about your pithy commentary or
something I was I was very impressed
how many guys get the Commissioner to
shout about without actually pink
traffic what else is on your mind today
not much I mean I don't know why you're
having me on I was just I just texted 40
when he if somebody had mentioned that
that the idea of a placeholder and I
just texted him on Manny Diaz was a
placeholder at temple I mean you know
it's interesting like I don't have any
problem with what coaches do if coaches
want to break a contract or if an
employer wants to let a coach out of a
contract to go to another job you know
Lynn Swann can allow Kliff Kingsbury to
interview or not that's business they
pay for that right the only issue I have
is when
coaches are allowed to do this
willy-nilly --it it's no big deal and
everybody does his business and then
players are said to be breaking commits
they made a commitment and all this
stuff that really makes no sense when
they're their unpaid amateur students
and and that's really the issue that's
always sort of wild me up is why do we
why do we say somehow that commitment
means means something sacred when a
player makes it and and they're said to
be students to be treated like any of
and when a paid coach can run around do
whatever they want I'm not saying they
shouldn't be able to I'm saying that the
player should be allowed to to transfer
without their their former school saying
where they can and can't go and they
shouldn't have to sit out a year they
should be able to play the very next
year and okay I'll give you an example
down like in basketball a lot of players
they're probably 75 to 100 players that
just transfer during the Christmas break
and the reason they do is so they can be
eligible at the at the start of next
Christmas break so they don't have to
say in players you know you'll hear
coaches say all the time he'll players
never stick it out when it gets tough
when adversity hits they just turn and
run and you say okay well why don't you
just let them transfer when they feel
like it and but but they can't play
until the next year that's a reasonable
thing for competition well that means
players that are transferring now
basketball players will stick out the
ear that they'll play so you'll get the
year of service out of them and you'll
have six more months to work it out with
them and to reasonable with them and and
maybe they'll work through it and become
a starter or become a star or whatever
the heck they want to be and why don't
we why don't we look at in a more
reasonable fashion than just you know
taking this iron-fisted approach of and
and it's not just iron-fisted they're
protecting an asset that they have the
universities and they're basically using
this one year you know year in residence
rule as the equivalent of a non-compete
provision for an employee so that that's
really the sort of the issue talking to
Jay Bilas from the mothership joining us
Dan Patrick show if you represented
Trevor Lawrence's family let's say they
wanted to challenge this because he's
never gonna be hotter than he is today
after winning that national title but
could you present a case in a court room
that would allow Trevor Lawrence to go
to the NFL early no it would never get
through a courtroom Maurice Clarett was
the last one to try this this is all
sort of not a Ryan I trust law there's a
it's it's from the collective bargaining
agreement this issue was collectively
bargained between the Players
Association and and the NFL so it's a
it's a special exception to federal
antitrust
and so what's always been really
interesting to me dan is sort of this
idea that people say well you know you
can go pro in the NBA out of high school
because you know players physically can
do it they can't do it the NFL they get
killed well that's first of all not the
reason that there's that three-year rule
years and years ago back when the NFL
was just getting started
the n-c-double-a put in a rule that if
you worked in any capacity in
professional sports you were no longer
eligible to work in college ones so if
you were official and you Resta game
professionally you could no longer work
in college if you were you know and
administer anything a coach and work
professionally you could no longer work
in college so the NFL basically came to
the NC double-a which was um ten twenty
times bigger than the NFL was a
fledgling league then I thought at the
time they came on bended knee and said
listen don't do this you'll kill us
we'll never get off the ground
we'll leave your players alone until
they graduate how about that and that's
where the four year old came now you
know why it's three now no the USFL in
1984 the USFL started drafting juniors
and they were taking the NFL's talent
away and so the NFL hadn't really
couldn't breath until the great until
four years till he graduated and so
that's when the NFL changed the rule and
like I heard you guys talk about four
let's write if the NFL had the
opportunity I think it'd be just
basketball if the NFL had the
opportunity to draft good talent when it
was younger they do it just to get it if
you could draft Trevor Lawrence right
now you'd wait on him because he'd be
worth it given given and reliance that
the NFL has on quarterback play and so
you'd have the same thing now and I
heard the Christian Hackenberg thing
you'd make mistakes the NFL makes plenty
of mistakes in the draft they make just
as many mistakes as the NBA does and
they have five years to look at these
players it's not an exact science in any
sport but but that's all that's all the
the draft eligibility rules are it's
three years because of a historic
precedent that has lasted and and that
started at 4:00 and went to three
because of the USFL and it was all
business that
to do with whether they could compete or
Western or what's American or an
American had nothing to do with that
basketball is a totally different
history and that's why their rule is
totally different but did David Robinson
get paid when he was drafted 1987 I
believe he sat for two years was he
getting paid by the Spurs I don't I
don't know because he was he was in the
Navy at the time so there were no
amateurism issues there so I don't know
the answer to that I do know that the
rules were different in 79 and 78 was
when when Red Auerbach drafted Larry
Bird it when he was a junior in 1978
there were nobody had thought of that
before and there was no rule against it
so Larry Bird did not get any money they
just held his drought in 1979 with you
senior he didn't get any money
there was nothing put in trust it was
just it was just Boston held his rights
and people there were some criticism of
Red Auerbach at the time saying that
what are you doing I mean you're wasting
a whole year and he basically said you
know a little time here is when you're
talking about a great player he said
this is gonna this is going to benefit
and that's when when Larry Bird came in
and Red Auerbach outsmarted the system
the NBA changed the rule they so you
couldn't do that anymore because
otherwise you'd have you know you would
have had guys drafting Michael Jordan
when he was freshman or things like that
where you can identify heck this player
is going to be great we'd be willing to
wait heck we saw the same thing
essentially even though it's a little
bit different but it's essentially the
same thing with Joelle and beat you know
Philly drafted him when he was injured
and they had to wait two years and and I
remember having the discussion well
would you take him when he's a junior
would you use that pick if you're still
in college and say well wait to your
junior yeah of course you would if you
have something transcendent that you
think could be you know Hall of Fame
caliber that's gonna last you a dozen
years and you know you give two years
back on the front end to get an
experienced player it's gonna last a
long time I'll leave you with this if
you have the first pick in the NBA Draft
who are you taking right now I'm taking
Zion Williams son but I'm still weaving
it open for our Jay Paris because I
think he's James Harden esque is in his
ability to get to the basket neither one
of them shoot it right now but they both
shoot us they don't
now you know bad mechanics they're just
not natural but I've never seen anything
like Zion Williamson on a basketball
court probably because there's never
been anybody like him he's not the best
player I've ever seen but but there's
never been a player like him to play
this game he's remarkable Jay thanks for
joining us as always we appreciate the
time thank you Dan
Jay Bilas from the mothership there for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]